- I'm Dr. Roshini Raj.
I'm an Internist and
Gastroenterologist and
an Associate Professor of Medicine.
- I'm Dr. Gail Saltz.
I am Clinical Associate
Professor of Psychiatry.
- I am a Family Medicine
Practitioner, and I'm here today
to talk to you about why
we should not be putting
laundry detergent pods in your mouth.
I can't believe I have to say this.
(upbeat music)
In 2018 already, there's been 39 cases in
the last two weeks, which
is enormous in comparison
to previous years, and it's in response to
a prank or a meme.
- Teenagers, or even adults
have taken this challenge
where they are swallowing detergent pods.
This is a horrible idea.
It can be very damaging,
not only to your mouth,
but to your esophagus and
your stomach, your lungs
potentially, and in some
cases, it can even be fatal.
- Long before this challenge was an issue,
very young children who
came upon a pod were at risk
for eating it, or swallowing
it because they mistook it
for a candy.
- Pretty small and so
like, bite sized, and so
I think the idea is like,
well, if it's bite sized
then it can't be that harmful.
- It's brightly colored, it's
multicolored, it's squishy,
it has a smooth coating
that can be manipulated.
People often wanna hold
it, manipulate it, or
unfortunately, put it in their mouth.
- The detergent pods contain,
in many cases, either
bleach like detergents, or
other, what we call surfactants,
which are very damaging
chemicals when your body
is exposed to them.
We have a very delicate
lining of our esophagus and
our stomach, and even our
mouth, and this can be
easily burned by these types of chemicals.
When you first put one of
these pods in your mouth
it's very likely to explode
because it's just kind of
contained in a plastic coating.
- It can dissolve with a
quick bite, and it also
can dissolve with just
like, mouth moisture.
So it doesn't necessarily
have to be your chomping
down on it.
- And this explosion
in your mouth can cause
severe burning of the
membranes that are lining
your mouth and your throat.
If you then swallow the
pod, it can go on to cause
severe burning of your esophagus.
This kind of damage could
even cause a tear in
your esophagus, or an
actual hole, and long term
can lead to narrowing or
stricturing of the esophagus.
It can really irritate
or burn the lining of
your stomach, and irritate
your intestines as well.
- When you're taking a bite
of it, if you actually end up
inhaling it, then you can get
some of the laundry detergent
into your lungs and at
that point it can irritate
sort of the lung lining,
causing you to cough, wheeze,
have shortness of breath,
and in some really serious
incidences can cause sort
of inflammation of the lungs
leading to pulmonary edema,
which is water in the lungs,
and acute respiratory distress
syndrome, where there's
too much inflammation for
you to be able to breathe.
- Taking a high risk prank
to the nth degree is not new.
Young adults are very drawn
to high risk behaviors
for biological reasons.
The amygdala sort of says
to the rest of the brain,
hey that felt good, let's
do it again, which is why
this age group has a particular
risk for doing things
that otherwise they
might deem a poor idea.
- This is such a disturbing
trend on many levels,
I think, because of social media.
Teenagers are doing a
lot of things that maybe
they wouldn't have done
20 years ago, just 'cause
they don't have an audience for it.
- So the same dynamic can
be at play, for example,
with something like the ALS
bucket challenge, where,
you know, where like wildfire, it took on.
It's simply the phenomenon
that large groups can see
an activity and can get
feedback for that activity
much more quickly because of social media.
- You absolutely can die from ingesting
laundry detergent pods.
For adults, it's not
necessarily gonna be the pods
themselves that lead to the risk of death.
Meaning you can get seizures,
you can get pulmonary edema,
or you can just have a
significant infection that can
develop as well.
- If you're worried about
someone you know potentially
swallowing a pod, certain
symptoms to look out for are:
abdominal pain, vomiting, nausea, fever.
- Right away, you wanna drink
a glass of water, you wanna
drink some milk to dilute the detergent.
You want to call poison
control right away.
Make sure to have details:
what was actually ingested,
the concentration, the ingredients.
You really don't want to make them vomit.
That can actually lead to
aspiration of the own vomit,
or choking on your own vomit.
But if any of the symptoms
ever get really serious,
you have to call 911 and get
to the closest emergency room.
- If you make something taboo, that's
simply gonna stoke them.
An adolescent and young adult,
this desire to take risk,
this desire to be anti
authoritarian may promote the desire
to do just that.
When these kinds of trends
come up, watching media,
you would have the feeling that
everybody's doing something.
Hey, everybody's doing
it, it must be okay.
Really look at the numbers,
which do remain very small.
Therefore keep that in mind.
- Please do not put laundry
detergent pods in your mouth,
even if you think it's
funny, if someone dares you,
whatever it may be, if
it reminds you of candy.
Just don't do it.
(upbeat music)